vous pensez qu'il est désormais
impossible de se rassembler pour danser
ensemble sans prendre de risques
inconsidérés pour votre santé
c'était sans compté sur l'inventivité de
ce groupe d'irlandais qui en pleine
crise du coronavirus s'est rassemblée
dans la rue pour faire la fête tout en
respectant les gestes barrière ses
habitants de dublin ont décidé de danser
sur une chorégraphie au rythme de la
chanson saturday night du chanteur
whitfield
mais pour eux pas question de prendre le
moindre risque c'est donc en conservant
une distance sociale suffisante entre
les danseurs que ces amateurs de bonne
humeur ont décidé de se lancer dans une
chorégraphie déjà culte
un journaliste présent sur place a pu
constater que rien n'avait été laissé au
hasard
en effet d'après le quotidien irlandais
irish poste au sol les places de chacun
avait été dessiné à la craie pour
s'assurer qu'ils gardent leur distance
un bon tuto qui pourra nous servir à
tous après le 11 mai pour pouvoir faire
la fête sans se mettre en danger
[Musique]
alors un valet agir à vis de magna qui
avait pas réagi sur les dons sur les
danseurs la de paris là dans le 18e
qu'est ce qu'elle dit quand elle voit
ses irlande elle mais quand je vois ces
irlandais est très bien d'autant plus
que je vois une maman à côté de ça chie
égal à créer et la petite ne respecte
pas le sacré et sa position et la maman
l'arpp la route cadre immédiatement yves
diba diba sur tabac sur ta trace est
comme ça respecte la distanciation
sociale donc voilà c'est civique c'est
respectueux et c'est formidable
est-ce qu'il va falloir faire à l'avenir
on n'a pas tout ce que vous avez pensé
dedans c'était pas un médecin dans le
xviiie vous mais j'ai pensé j'ai pensé
la même chose que la danse des berlinois
et qui a fait repartir le coefficient en
allemagne aujourd'hui et qui fait que
peut-être que l'allemagne d'aujourd'hui
va devoir être recompilé voilà c'est à
dire que il faut absolument qu'on soit
des confiné mais il faut constater
confinés dans le respect de toutes les
mesures sanitaires et s'était
complètement inconséquent et c'était
pacifique et s'était complètement
irresponsable alors malheureusement
voilà bah merci ça fait du bien de
retrouver céline c'est littéraire qu'est
ce qui se passe à la disent assez
littéraire assez carré ans canadien mais
merci juste en tout cas je tiens à
souligner le début d'émission de raymond
qui est un de ses meilleurs de
l'histoire un an vraiment c'est
quelqu'un qui a décidé de mettre les
bouchées nous là ils voient qu'on au
troisième trimestre celles à ce qu'on
sache si cela est ou relire il a bossé
comme un pou